Wir können nichts mehr ändern.
Jetzt müssen wir raus.
Es gibt kein Zurück mehr.
- Nein.
Nun wird sich
in einer ersten Phase zeigen,
ob sich die Arbeit der letzten
paar Monate gelohnt hat. - Mhm.
Premiere für Rene Rindlisbacher
und seine Tochter Laura -
als neues Bühnen-Duo.
Seine Komikererfahrung:
33 Jahre.
Ihre: null.
Kann das gut gehen?
Was macht so ein Projekt
mit einer Vater-Tochter-Beziehung?
Davon handelt diese Geschichte.
* Jubel, Applaus *
Bist du bereit?
- Mhm.
Probenstart.
Bist du wirklich bereit?
- Mhm.
Rindlisbacher überreicht
seiner Tochter den Text.
Ich begleite die beiden von nun an
bis zur Premiere in zehn Wochen.
Wir müssen herausfinden, wie spontan
du improvisieren kannst etc.
Z.B. die Urologin:
Nehmen wir mal an, äh ...
... sie wäre dialektmässig
in Bern oder St. Gallen angesiedelt?
St. Gallen.
Einfach nur ...
Es interessiert mich einfach. - Mhm.
Wenn jetzt du das ...
Nehmen wir mal an ...
Hier, was?
- Hier.
(Mit St.-Galler-Dialekt) Hallo
Herr Rindlisbacher, setzen Sie sich!
Das ist schon mal gut.
Rene Rindlisbacher: einer
der berühmtesten Komiker der Schweiz.
Den Durchbruch schaffte er
1986 mit den Schmirinskis -
zusammen mit Stefan Schmidlin.
Guten Tag.
- (Mit Berner Dialekt) Guten Tag.
Woher?
- Bümpliz.
* Lachen *
Das liegt im Kanton Bern.
Ha, das hört man gar nicht.
Ja, bin ich zu schnell?
* Lachen *
Danach knüpfte er mit Edelmais
an diese Erfolge an -
zusammen mit Sven Furrer.
(Mit italienischem Akzent) Leck mir
am Arsch mit der Laktoseintoleranz.
Wer wissen will,
was Laktoseintoleranz ist,
kann Gretteler fragen.
(Mit holländischem Akzent ) Weisst
du, was ich an dir so schätze?
Nein.
- Gar nix.
Nach dem Ende von Edelmais
stellte man ihm
immer wieder die gleiche Frage.
"Mit wem wirst du auf der Bühne
stehen?" Ich weiss es nicht.
Aber jetzt
kann ich mir alles vorstellen:
mit einem Freund,
Schauspieler oder Komiker.
Ich kann mir auch vorstellen,
mit meinen Kindern
auf der Bühne zu stehen.
Diese Aussage
wurde von vielen aufgenommen.
Im nächsten Interview
hiess es tatsächlich,
ich wolle ja anscheinend mit
meiner Tochter auf der Bühne stehen.
Das ging sehr schnell.
Ich sagte: "Ach, ja?"
D.h., es wurde aufgegriffen.
Als man mich das zum ersten Mal
ganz konkret fragte, dachte ich:
dachte ich: "Das wäre
eigentlich eine gute Idee."
Sie sagte sofort Ja.
Laura Rindlisbacher stand
schon immer gerne im Mittelpunkt,
spielte als Kind und Jugendliche
Theater.
Kürzlich
wurde mir das wieder bewusst.
Als sie für Edelmais probten,
interessierte es mich immer total,
wie sie dabei vorgingen,
wie sie zusammensassen, darüber
redeten und wie das genau ...
Ich bekam ja mit, dass sie probten
und wollte auch gerne wissen,
wie das so läuft.
Darum war für mich klar:
"Ja, das machen wir."
Die 25-Jährige
kündigte ihre Stelle in einem Büro.
Denn die Zeit ist knapp.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Zwei Wochen später: Ich begleite
Rene Rindlisbacher nach Basel -
zu seinem Co-Autor.
Er fährt mit dem Zug:
gezwungenermassen.
Den Fahrausweis musste
der Komiker vor einem Jahr abgeben.
Er verursachte mit Alkohol im Blut
eine Frontalkollision.
In der Presse ein grosses Thema -
über Wochen.
Ich bin wirklich nicht sicher,
ob ich überhaupt
je wieder Auto fahren möchte.
Ich hatte ja bereits
einen Unfall wegen Epilepsie.
Damals sagte ich mir: "Du darfst
einfach nicht Auto fahren."
Wenn man
einen epileptischen Anfall hatte,
darf man danach sowieso
ein Jahr lang nicht Auto fahren.
Während der Zeit, in der ich
sowieso nicht Auto fahren durfte,
hatte ich einen kleinen Anfall.
Dieser zeigte mir,
dass ich das
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr tun werde.
Wenn jetzt wieder
etwas passieren würde -
ich müsste nicht mal Schuld sein,
ich wäre einfach
in einen Unfall verwickelt -,
würde das
die Öffentlichkeit nicht verstehen.
Das ist das eine.
Das andere ist, dass ich
nicht nochmals hilflos erwachen
und mich fragen möchte,
was geschehen ist.
Wenn man das mal erlebt hat,
weiss man genau,
dass das der Horror ist.
Epilepsie ist nicht die einzige
Krankheit von Rindlisbacher -
davon später mehr.
Es gibt einen Buschauffeur
des Monats? - Ja, ja.
Duk-duk-duk-düggi-düggi-dük.
Carlito.
Verdammt, bist du gewachsen?
- Ja, seitlich ein wenig.
Hier und hier. Mehr nach vorn.
Und hinten?
- Äh ...
Zeig mal!
- Würdest du das Thema wechseln?
Wo?
- Hier runter. - Wie runter?
Carlos Amstutz spielt selber
Theater und führt ein Restaurant.
Bitte schön.
- (Mit Basler Dialekt) Danke schön.
Hier feilen sie an Pointen
und besprechen die bisherigen Proben.
Seine Tochter ist bei diesem Treffen
nicht dabei, aber ein Thema.
Ich sagte ihr zweimal -
sie war noch hier:
"Hör zu, Laura, wenn das
nach drei Tagen nicht klappt,
können wir wieder aufhören."
"Dann hören wir auf.
Das hat keinen Sinn."
"Du bist nicht da oben ...
Du bist Komikerin."
"Dann musst du jetzt
auch wie eine Komikerin wirken."
Mhm.
- Und dann war sie wirklich ...
Es tat mir selbst weh, das zu sagen.
Aber es war nötig, dass wir
etwas hart zu einander waren.
Noch sieben Wochen bis zur Premiere.
Rene Rindlisbacher setzt
im neuen Programm auf Bewährtes -
auf seine beliebtesten Rollen.
Parallel dazu
fliesst viel Privates ein.
Ich bin gleich bei euch.
* Sie atmet tief aus. *
Laura, du kannst das.
Lass dich nicht
von solchen Dingen beeinflussen!
Du kannst das. Du bist da
und dir kann nichts passieren.
Du bist ...
Wie sagt man?
... textsicher.
Das ist deine Bühne.
Das ist dein Moment.
(Enthusiastisch)
Und das ist dein Publikum.
Ja, zelebrier das!
* Lachen, tiefes Ausatmen *
Folgendes ist wichtig:
Wenn du da oben stehst,
ähm, solltest du nicht ...
... das Gefühl vermitteln,
dass du auf der Suche bist. - Mhm.
"Grossartig" und "Wow" zu sagen,
macht nur Sinn,
wenn du das auch ...
(Begeistert) Wow!
Du musst es so meinen.
(Gleichgültig) Wow. Grossartig. Wow.
Nein, so nicht. Wenn du das tust,
musst du erstarren.
(Begeistert) Wow!
Das ist ja Wahnsinn!
Ich sehe, wie er es macht
und was er mir mitgeben will.
Und, äh ...
Ich möchte das umsetzen,
kriege es aber nicht so hin wie er.
Das ist jeweils schon frustrierend.
Ich bewundere Lauras Mut.
Ist Humor lernbar? Oder gar vererbt?
Das ist naturgegeben.
Ich habe das ...
Mein Vater war bereits ...
Wie soll ich das ausdrücken?
Er unterhielt bereits die Leute.
Ich tat das bereits in der Schule.
Im Kindergarten war ich
beim Unsinnmachen immer zuvorderst.
Wenn man uns
bei etwas Verbotenem erwischte,
konnte ich die Situation
durch eine witzige
oder komische Antwort retten.
Es ist einfach ...
In der Schule war das auch so.
An Klassentreffen sagen alle:
"Wir wussten immer,
dass du das mal machen wirst."
Das zog sich gewiss
durch mein ganzes Leben hindurch.
Ab sofort sind die beiden
nicht mehr nur Vater und Tochter,
sondern auch Geschäftspartner.
Auch die Werbung machen sie selber.
- So süss!
Schade,
dass das nicht so geblieben ist.
Hier suchen sie
ein Foto für Social Media.
Genau. - Du machst ein Foto
und lädst es gleich hoch.
Warte! Soll ich es für dich halten?
- Mhm.
So.
Es muss scharf sein.
- Schau, der Rand! So.
* Kameraauslöser *
Sechs Wochen vor der Premiere treffe
ich Rene Rindlisbacher in Luzern.
Gut, dass ich noch nie hier war.
Ein Krankenbesuch
zusammen mit Sohn Nico.
Laura hat sich beim Skifahren
die Bänder gerissen.
Sie musste operiert werden.
(Nico) Hallo.
- Ja, hallöchen. - Ja, hallöchen.
* Lachen *
Hey, das sieht ja richtig ...
... professionell aus.
- ... professionell aus.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Hallo, Schnucki.
Hallo, Papichen.
Schön, was?
Dir geht es ja gut.
Schau dir das an!
Druck hatten sie schon vorher,
jetzt kommt noch der Unfall dazu.
Wir können nicht mehr abwarten,
sondern müssen voll ran.
Wenn wir zuvor Pausen machten,
sagten wir:
"Ja, ja, das ist schon okay." Nun
machen wir halt keine Pausen mehr.
Du bist der Einzige,
der dieses Jahr noch nichts hatte.
Das gab es noch nie.
Mama hat nie etwas
und Nico eigentlich auch nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Und jetzt ist es gerade ...
... umgekehrt.
Dieses Jahr waren Moni und Laura
bereits
wegen einer Operation im Spital.
Bei Moni war es der Rücken,
bei Laura nun das Kreuzband.
Nico hatte
eine ganz schwere Schuhrandprellung
und konnte
zwei Wochen lang nur noch liegen.
Und ich bin fit wie ein junges Reh.
Das war nicht immer so.
Renes Krankenakte ist lang:
angeborener Herzfehler, Epilepsie,
Ohnmachtsanfälle, Nierenkoliken,
Herz- und Hirnoperationen,
Schlafapnoe, Tinnitus, Arthritis.
Und Depressionen.
Angefangen haben diese 2006 -
kurz vor einer Premiere.
Das Publikum bereits im Saal,
er in der Garderobe.
Ich tat mir körperlich weh.
Ich verspürte wirklich Schmerzen.
Ich merkte richtig,
wie sich etwas in mir verkrampfte.
Eine Verkrampfung
ist etwas vom Schlimmsten,
wenn man locker sein sollte.
Die Schmerzen kamen von innen.
Zweitens war es so, dass ...
Ich merkte, dass alles,
was war, wieder hochkam.
Ich versuchte, es einzuordnen,
aber das funktionierte nicht.
Die Premiere sagten sie ab.
Er nahm sich eine Auszeit.
Auf Medikamente verzichtete er.
Heute würde er sich besser spüren.
Er habe gelernt,
mit den Depressionen zu leben.
Den genauen Grund
für diese kenne er nicht.
Ja, was ist denn?
* Bellen *
Ja, was ist denn? Guten Tag.
Das ist doch auch schön.
Da bellen Hunde.
Man fragt sich:
"Wieso bellen die Hunde mich an?"
"Oder bellen sie
bei fremden Leuten einfach immer?"
Man weiss es nicht.
Solche Dinge
kann man nie wirklich ergründen.
Meiner Meinung nach sollte es
auch beim Menschen nicht so sein,
dass man
wie eine Maschine funktioniert
und immer genau weiss, was man
tun soll, damit alles stimmt.
Aber man muss auf sich selbst hören.
Man muss herausfinden,
was einem wirklich ...
... wirklich gut tut.
Für ihn ist klar: In seinem Leben
passiert nichts ohne Grund.
Ich weiss, dass es vor
und nach dem Leben nicht dunkel ist.
Das ist mir bewusst.
Ich habe zu viel erlebt,
das mich ...
... das dafür spricht,
dass ich meine Schutzengel habe.
Und ähm ...
Daher weiss ich, dass es etwas gibt,
das uns begleitet.
Da bin ich mir ganz sicher.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Seine Krankheiten haben ihn und
seine Familie zusammengeschweisst.
Der 55-Jährige sagt mir:
"Die Familie ist das einzige,
was funktionieren muss,
damit es funktioniert."
(Moni) Durch die Limetten
ist es etwas Besonderes.
Meldet euch, wenn ich helfen kann!
Ja, es wäre gut,
wenn du auch ein bisschen ...
Ist das immer so?
Alle arbeiten - bis auf den Maestro?
Nein.
* Lachen *
Hallo? Ich helfe,
wenn es wirklich nötig ist.
Weisst du, schneiden und zubereiten,
das ist alles ...
Das kann jeder.
Aber wenn es darauf ankommt,
muss man dabei sein.
Rene Rindlisbacher
ist nicht fürs Kochen zuständig,
sondern für den Humor.
Er ist halt nicht Komiker von Beruf,
sondern er ist als Mensch Komiker.
(Moni) Ja.
- Das ist der Unterschied.
Darum ist es bei uns
immer ziemlich lustig.
Auch wenn ich das
nicht gerne zugebe.
Ab und zu ist es ziemlich lustig.
Zum Wohl, Schatz.
- Zum Wohl ...
... Schnucki.
Mit seiner Frau Monika
ist er seit 27 Jahren verheiratet.
Sie sagt, er sei ein Stehaufmännchen,
sehe in allem etwas Positives -
selbst in seinen Krankheiten.
Ich war immer jemand, der sagte:
"Oh, wir müssen uns Gedanken
darüber machen, wie es weitergeht."
Dann beruhigte mich Rene immer
und sagte:
"Nein, wenn es so weit ist,
ist es immer noch früh genug,
um uns Gedanken zu machen."
Gut, danke.
Die Rindlisbachers -
ein eingeschworenes Quartett.
Das glaube ich.
- Guten Appetit.
Eine Zwetschge.
Habe ich eine Zwetschge?
Mit seiner Tochter
auf der Bühne zu stehen,
sieht Rindlisbacher
nicht zuletzt deshalb als Vorteil.
Sie sei eine engere Bezugsperson
als die früheren Partner.
Zwei Wochen vor der Premiere:
Laura Rindlisbacher
wieder ohne Krücken.
Nächster Halt: Affoltern am Albis.
Ja, ich habe das sogar
mit nach Hause genommen.
Ja, zu meiner Frau sagte ich immer:
"Schätzchen,
nächster Halt: Waschküche."
Ja, haben wir gelacht - also ich.
Immer wenn ich dabei bin,
das gleiche Bild:
Dann machst du halt den da.
- Ja.
Er zeigt vor, sie spielt nach.
Du musst dich etwas beeilen.
Und dann kommst du hier nach vorn.
Du stellst dich neben mich.
* Er ahmt das Schliessen der Türen
und den Motor nach. *
Sie haben schon gemerkt,
dass das eine Kurve war, oder?
dass wir auf einer Bühne stehen?
Wie sieht es mit dem Griff aus?
Ist der so weit unten?
* Gestelltes Lachen *
Et voila.
Ich sag's nicht gerne,
aber sie macht's gut.
Nein, sie hat jetzt Freude daran.
Hier auf der Bühne
sieht alles anders aus,
als wenn man irgendwo auf der Couch
sitzt und das Ganze macht.
Sie macht es wirklich gut.
... wirklich
etwas schicker angezogen.
Rindlisbacher
hat klare Vorstellungen.
Diese bespricht er
mit Co-Autor Carlos Amstutz.
Seine Tochter hält sich zurück.
Vielleicht etwas ... Das Jackett
nicht richtig zu oder so.
Er hat seine Visionen und weiss:
So und so geht es.
Ich habe das nicht oder noch nicht.
Ich vertraue ihm zu 100 %.
Er sagt mir: "So und so und so."
Und dann funktioniert es auch.
Vieles ist neu in ihrem Leben.
Etwas ist geblieben:
Cantamessa.
Für sie fand Laura Rindlisbacher
trotz intensiver Proben Zeit.
So.
Ich war quasi
frustriert und blockiert.
Ich dachte: "Scheisse,
ich möchte niemanden enttäuschen."
Hör jetzt auf!
Ich hatte zunächst Angst, dass ich
die Texte nicht auswendig kann.
Ich dachte mal wirklich:
"Ich schaffe es nicht,
alles auswendig zu lernen.
Jetzt funktioniert es einigermassen.
Ich konnte auch ihm
anders vorspielen.
Und jetzt, seit meinem Unfall ...
Ich hatte das Gefühl, als hätte das
irgendwie einen Knoten gelöst.
Ich musste wirklich liegen und
nutzte dann diese Zeit zum Lernen.
So war ich danach viel freier.
Sie will auf die Bühne.
Und zwar nicht
einfach nur als "Tochter von ...".
Damit hat sie in ihrer Jugend
oft zu kämpfen gehabt.
Das ist ein Top-Service.
Alle meinten immer: "Ja, sie
ist halt Rindlisbachers Tochter -
die haben halt das und das
und machen das
und haben wahrscheinlich
auch in der Schule einen Bonus."
Damit hatte ich grosse Mühe.
Was machst du?
Darfst du auf der Weide sein?
Tag der Premiere,
in Affoltern am Albis.
650 Zuschauer werden erwartet.
Noch ist Laura Rindlisbacher ruhig.
Ich bin selbst erstaunt darüber.
Auch die letzten Tage ...
Freunde von mir sagen,
sie seien wohl nervöser als ich.
Sie schrieb mir gestern auch,
ob ich nervös sei. Aber nein.
Und sie: "Ich bin für dich nervös."
Zehn Wochen Proben
liegen hinter den Rindlisbachers.
Eine Zeit, in der sie neue Seiten
aneinander entdeckt haben.
Früher hatte sie immer das Gefühl:
"Ja, ja, das kommt dann auch."
Das hatte sie auch von mir,
aber ich kann es mir leisten,
nach 30 Jahren Bühne
lockerer zu sein.
Aber sie hat es
hervorragend hingekriegt.
Sie selbst hat sich Ziele gesetzt:
"Bis dann will ich das und das."
Das kannte ich früher
nicht so von ihr.
Es geht los.
* Vereinzeltes Lachen *
Sie haben schon gemerkt, dass wir
eine Kurve gemacht haben, oder?
* Lachen *
Sie haben schon gemerkt,
dass wir auf einer Bühne stehen?
* Lachen *
Sie haben schon gemerkt,
dass der Griff etwas weit unten ist?
Immer noch keine Spur von Nervosität
bei Laura Rindlisbacher.
Endlich, jetzt ist er da:
mein Moment.
Ich bin überrascht,
wie locker sie ist.
Selbst als ihr Vater
seinen Auftritt verpasst.
... alle.
* Lachen *
Hä?
So, geht es bei dir?
Hast du den PRIX WALO gefunden?
- Hey ...
* Keuchen *
Hey ...
* Er lacht. *
Ich habe mir den Fuss verknackst,
als ich runter bin.
Die Zuschauer denken,
es sei ein Witz.
Dabei ist er hinter der Bühne
wirklich gestürzt.
Machen wir weiter?
- Ja. Wo?
* Er lacht. *
Was war da schon wieder?
* Lachen *
Blöd,
wenn beide nicht mehr weiterwissen.
Weiss jemand von euch weiter?
* Lachen *
Philipp? Hä?
- Mami?
(Leise) Der Sohn des Professors.
Was?
- Der Sohn des Professors.
Dort waren wir, ja.
- (Mann) Das Gesicht.
Die Probleme
beginnen mit dem Gesicht. - Ja.
* Rene lacht. *
Er muss den Text holen. Sein Sturz
wirft beide aus dem Konzept.
Immer wieder kommt es zu
kleinen Aussetzern. Bis zum Schluss.
Dem Publikum gefällt es trotzdem.
* Jubel, Applaus *
Laura Rindlisbacher hat die
Feuertaufe als Komikerin bestanden.
Der Routinier hingegen
ist enttäuscht.
Das ist einfach blöd, denn man
arbeitet monatelang darauf hin
und meint:
"Mit der Premiere ist es so weit."
Es war seltsam,
als er nicht weiterwusste.
Ich dachte: "Das kann nicht sein."
Denn er weiss sonst immer,
wie er es retten kann.
Deshalb wusste ich,
dass was passiert war.
Man merkte es wohl
bis zum Schluss nicht.
Ich hätte ihr gerne
einen besseren Schluss gegönnt
an ihrer Premiere.
Müssen wir dir Krücken holen?
- Nein.
Ich hätte noch welche.
Diese Geschichte hat kein Happy End.
Aber Rene Rindlisbacher
ist ja ein Stehaufmännchen.